President Joe Biden was confronted
Yesterday by Fox news reporter Peter
Ducey about the growing headache that
these classified documents are becoming
for the Biden Administration oh but
David you'll never talk about this say
so many of you that email me I've talked
about it all along oh but David you'll
say that it shouldn't even be
investigated no as I've said all along
investigate everything investigate
everything and come to whatever
conclusions the facts point to the
latest news from the Associated Press
Biden team finds more documents with
classified markings President Joe
Biden's legal team has discovered
additional documents containing
classification markings in a second
location this comes a day a days after
an attorney for Biden's for president
said Biden's lawyers had discovered a
small number of documents
um the person who spoke to the AP
Wednesday said the president's legal
team found additional material
classified material at a second location
they are talking about a garage Peter
Ducey confronts Joe Biden yesterday
about this and here is how that
conversation went
material
let me uh look I'm going to get a chance
to speak on all this God willing soon
but as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvettes in
the lock garage okay so it's not like
you're sitting out in the street but
anyway
yes as well as my Corvette
um but as I said earlier this week
people know I take classified documents
and classified materials seriously
I also said we're cooperating fully and
completely the Justice Department's
review
as part of that process my lawyers
reviewed other places where documents in
my uh of from my time as vice president
were stored and they finished the review
last night
they discovered a small number of
documents of classified markings and
storage areas and file cabinets in my
home and my in my my my personal Library
this was done in the case of the Biden
pens and that this was done in the case
of the Biden Pen Center the Department
of Justice was immediately as was done
the Department of Justice was
immediately so I uh the the reading of
this statement is not going particularly
well for Joe Biden
um Jason kander had a very good tweet
about the contrast between the Biden and
the Trump classified document situation
now those of you who really know me know
that I could not care less about whether
there's a d or an R next to Joe Biden or
Trump's name when it comes to how these
situations should be handled investigate
all of them and I think what will become
very clear as a piece of my microphone
just exploded uh is that the
circumstances are of course so
dramatically different and Jason
kander's tweet was quote
classified documents a shopping analogy
as Biden walked out the buzzer went off
and he realized he mistakenly failed to
pay for an item in his cart he went back
in and returned it Trump stuffed items
in his pockets when the buzzer sounded
he ran to his car and peeled out I have
said it all week and I will say it again
investigate everyone this doesn't
exonerate Donald Trump any more than an
accused murderer would be exonerated
because of someone else accused of
murder somewhere else in a completely
unrelated case these are two completely
separate things
the facts are different the reaction was
different the circumstances are
different and it's so evident that
everything about these two situations is
so so different so Fox is getting a lot
of mileage from this Donald Trump I'm
sure is thrilled about the fact that
this is going on
but these are two very different
situations they should both be
investigated and let's let the cards
fall where they may see how I'm not
saying oh but let the cards fall where
they may and Peter Ducey is gonna get
his licks there's no doubt about it
um but uh it does not do a damn thing to
exonerate Donald Trump the moral compass
of the Republican Party could not
possibly be better
illuminated than by Matt Gates
interviewing George Santos slash Anthony
devolder slash Anthony Santos slash
George devolder whatever name you know
him by I'm talking about the liar who
was elected to congress he appeared on I
guess Matt Gates's show I didn't even
know Matt Gates had a show but I guess
he does on real America's voice
and the interview is like nothing I have
ever seen I don't know who thought this
was a good idea the pressure is building
on George Anthony Santos de volder to
resign I don't know that this interview
is going to save him but you have to see
this here is George Santos saying he has
lived an honest life I've worked my
entire life I've lived an honest life
I've never been uh accused shoot of any
bad doing so that's untrue he is
actually been accused of crimes in
Brazil already and there are multiple
criminal investigations but okay that's
a lie oh you know he's lying about not
lying right now before your very eyes
it's my it's the equity of my hard
working self and I've invested inside of
me like I said didn't come from he
invested inside of himself deep deep
inside of himself and he found that he
is an honest man Charisma it didn't come
for Ukraine Russia China unlike some
folks that we all know that get money
from those sources yeah
um okay so then Matt Gates asks him
where did your campaign funding come
from and he again repeats this cute
little line uh one of the principal
critiques I've heard is that a lot of
money uh was donated to your campaign by
you 700 000 I believe where did it come
from well I'll tell you where it didn't
come from it didn't come from China
Ukraine or barisma how about that well
yeah that that is an answer that is not
actually an answer we finally figured
out the funding actually came from
uh what was that country Trump made up
nambia
um it's not an answer and he is being
dis this interview is to prove how
honest he is and he can't stop lying or
or obscuring the truth during this
actual interview here's another moment
during which Gates says listen sure you
embellished your resume but everybody in
Congress has embellished their resumes
we'd have no one in Congress if
embellishing your resume got you kicked
out you have admitted embellishing your
resume you've acknowledged it you've
apologized for it uh some have said that
you shouldn't be seated on committees
for it I would offer that if we didn't
see people on committees who embellish
their resume running for congress we
probably wouldn't be able to make Quorum
in any of those committees other people
embellish so everything's fine do you do
you uh now have a sense of the
Committees you want to serve on the type
of work you want to do I came to DC
Without Really any preconceived notions
of what committees to serve yeah he came
to see DC without any preconceived
notion about what the hell the job
entails whether what I can give to the
American people whatever committee I'm
given whether it's I don't know science
and technology or education and labor or
whatever committee is thrown my way I
will deliver 110 because that's what I
know how to do I'm going to outwork any
of the pundits and Talking Heads pundits
the word is pundits pundits come on dude
that are out there saying that I should
resign that I'm unfit for office the
reality is and the and the the the the
the the the case and point here being is
I'm a Workhorse I've worked my whole
life I'm the kid who came from a
basement Department you weren't supposed
to win this season I was not supposed to
win this season yeah so Matt get I don't
know how Matt Gates ended up doing this
Rehabilitation attempt of George Santos
Anthony devolder and
um on the issue of resignation
here is what Santos had to say I I wish
well all of their opinions but I was
elected by 142 000 people until those
same 142 000 people tell me they don't
want me uh we'll find out in two years
what are those 142 000 people deserve in
a representative they deserve somebody
who's going to come here and fight and
not get involved with the media nonsense
that we're seeing take place right
nonsense now here's the problem
the 142 000 people
voted for a person that doesn't exist
and what I mean by that is they voted
for a fictional character who was a
volleyball star at Baroque College
who worked in High Finance who had
degrees that he doesn't really have
who's Jewish in a and the reason it's
relevant is it's a it's a district with
a significant Jewish population and he
told stories about his Judaism
it they voted for someone that doesn't
exist and so to say well they now don't
get a say until two years from now
because they already voted for him they
voted for someone who is not the person
actually representing them so Gates is
now sucked into it we don't know what
exactly is behind Gates doing this
interview but what is stunning
is that these are softball interviews
these are meant to be interviews so easy
that they make him look prepared and
honest and qualified and forthcoming and
all these things
he obviously and brazenly continues to
lie in interviews designed to be easy
for him to at least pretend to be an
honest person let's hope that he's gone
by Monday although Anything Could Happen
make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel we are pushing for 2
million YouTube subscribers this year it
is early on in the year and uh
youtube.com the davidpackman show is the
place to hit that subscribe button
doesn't change anything doesn't cost
anything you're just saying I like what
you're doing YouTube recommend this
stuff to more people that's essentially
what you're saying I'll give you an
update on uh the progress towards 2
million probably late next week
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is of course
funded by our viewers and listeners
through the membership program if you
think maybe this is a thing that we want
to see continue you can sign up at
joinpakman.com we'll give you instant
access to the world famous bonus show
every day for our members you'll also
get commercial free audio and video
feeds of the show every weekday made
available hours before the show is
published to everybody else all really
great things and it's cheap folks it's
very cheap you can go to joinpakman.com
use the code please no more Trump
please no more Trump say it in your head
that way when you type it in and you'll
get a discount and it'll be a beautiful
thing all right let's hear from people
in the audience my favorite people we
take calls on the Friday show via
Discord at davidpackman.com Discord once
you're there you go to the waiting Lobby
and you raise your hand you click raise
hand that way I know you want to talk to
me and it's a very very exciting thing
let's go first this is just first this
isn't this isn't the be all end-all
we're gonna go first to tie in Iowa
and see what is on Ty's mind Tai welcome
to the program
uh what's going on what's on your mind
today
hey David hey
how are you doing doing well well um
okay that's good all right um so I just
wanted to ask so you know how there was
the the riots and uh Brazil recently
right of course
yeah so
how how much do you think those were
probably inspired by January 6 do you
think well I think it was it's not only
the model from January 6th but Bannon
and Jason Miller and others affiliated
with Trump were advising jair bolsonaro
in November about quote next steps it's
like next steps dude you lost so it's
quite literally the same model the Q
Anon people seem to have potentially
been involved at least online in
fomenting what went on it's quite
literally a copycat thing and this was
exactly the concern
yeah I do think that um I don't feel
like there's going to be a whole like
hearing or something like that though I
can't really see that happening because
I think like he seems like he's been a
lot more silent than Trump has you know
yeah well he ended up in the hospital he
was he was in but bolsonaro was in
Florida at the time and he went to a KFC
he went to a Publix and then he ended up
in the hospital with abdominal pain I
mean it's a dramatically different
situation also they did start arresting
a bunch of people pretty damn quickly
down in Brazil doesn't mean that it was
perfectly handled but it doesn't seem as
though it's all going to go the same way
yeah you know what's what's crazy is
like there were actually even more
people or something but I think the
capital at January 6 is like 3 000 and
like at Brazil was like 4 000 but like
the area was vacant so it was a lot less
violent but I don't have those numbers
in front of me but that that is
interesting I will I will look into that
yeah
all right Ty well thank you very much I
appreciate it
I mean thank you too that's my dog
barking all right you might want to hang
all right say hi to your dog for me
there is Ty from Iowa with some very
very powerful declarations let's go next
to Jack from Connecticut Jack welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
good afternoon David thank you for
having me my pleasure watching your
content and it is very informative thank
you
um despite the fact that Donald Trump
was in my opinion one of the worst
Presidents in American history he uh was
able to open the American people's eyes
on the importance but also complicated
process of American democracy and I just
want your opinion what do you think will
be the worst case the best or worst case
scenario uh in the upcoming 2024
presidential election well the the worst
case is that Trump or someone even worse
becomes president and and we again have
a complete flouting of norms and and in
many cases the law the best case is that
you know a better candidate whether it's
Joe Biden or whoever wins and and
continues putting the country on a
slightly better path than it was headed
under Trump but I don't know that I
agree you know when when you said Jack
Trump opened the eyes of Americans to
the complexities of of our Democratic
process that's like putting a really
favorable spin on Trump basically
normalized authoritarianism among a
large swath of American voters I don't
know that it's really opening the eyes I
think it's I think that's too positive a
spin to put on what Trump did
of course absolutely I I absolutely hate
what he did on January it's like I was
just saying that from my perspective
because um I'm a big fan on US history I
was exempt from the U.S history Final in
high school there's a lot of things that
I did not know about in the process
because it wasn't really televised as
much the media wasn't paying oh Jackie
you're saying you're saying quite
literally like you just learned about
the process for like certifying the
electoral votes like they're in the
nitty-gritty you're saying you didn't
know about that you learned about that
yeah oh okay okay also the fact that
um people are paying much more attention
to that now as people as people have not
much has done in uh previous elections
okay that's that's fair that's fair I
think I thought you were saying
something different but uh yeah I mean
listen the worst case scenario for 24 is
very bad so let's work to prevent it
from becoming reality
100 yep all right my friend thank you
for the call thank you very much much
appreciated all right we are taking
calls right now if you'd like to speak
to me you can use the raise your hand
function which is a very very powerful
and important function I would say why
don't we speak next to Ryan from New
Hampshire Ryan welcome to the David
packman show what's on your mind today
hang on can you hear me yeah
great
um I just had a quick question I know
you talked about uh the vaccine and one
of your recent shows but
um my dad had said something
um about like healthy people who were
athletes dying and I was just wondering
how I could like combat that well what's
the claim that he's making he's he's
saying athletes have died what what does
he believe they died of
uh he sorry he said um just like Cardiac
Arrest or myocarditis I think okay which
athletes died of myocarditis
he that Holly was just 16 000.
sorry what
he just said see he read a report that
there was like 24 before covid a year
and now there's like 16 000 a year 16
000 athletes are dying of myocarditis
your dad believes
I that's what he's been told yeah
there's no I mean there's just no
evidence of that you know that we did a
story about this very very specifically
you've got to understand the base rate
okay 21 million people aged uh 18 to 24
received two doses of the vaccine 21
million people just based on General
death rates you would expect in a year
70
000 of those people to die
and that includes car accidents that
includes everything even if even if you
said oh uh there are 10 of these died
suddenly things or 20 or whatever you
know it does not tell us anything about
the vaccine and it does not even compare
mathematically to the number of those
people you would expect to die now in
terms of cardiac arrest you know Demar
Hamlin didn't die so even from Cardiac
Arrest I don't even know if Demar Hamlin
was vaccinated I don't even know that
it's been said I mean there's just the
problem with this is these people really
don't want to listen you know your dad
apparently read somewhere 16 000 people
died of myocarditis there's no evidence
of that it just seems like he wants to
live in that world and it's sad yeah
well thank you David I love listening to
your show all right Ryan uh good good
luck with your dad that sounds like a
very complicated situation uh remember
if you would like to get on with me your
nickname in the waiting Lobby should be
your name and where you're calling from
or where you're calling from and your
name those are the two important
components let's go to our friend Johnny
from Boston Johnny from Boston what's on
your mind today
hi David happy New Year likewise thanks
um two questions for you well they can
be all summarized in one please uh two
candid candidates running for 2024 in
the Senate uh Katie Porter in California
and Lucas Koontz in Missouri your
opinions on them as potential candidates
don't know a thing about the Missouri
race to be perfectly Frank I'll have to
inform myself about that we talked about
the Katie Porter situation earlier this
week on the award-winning bonus show and
um I think Katie Porter is fantastic the
one interesting thing is she's running
for Dianne Feinstein's seat Dianne
Feinstein has not actually said she's
retiring in 2024 a lot of signs point to
she should and maybe she will she would
be close to 95 at the end of the next
term if she were to win there are
concerns about cognitive decline her not
realizing that she's meeting people for
like the 10th time that she's met many
times asking the same questions over and
over again during hearings so there's a
lot of a lot of push for Dianne
Feinstein to retire putting aside the
Feinstein component I think Katie Porter
is super smart she's really good at
hearing she's really good at getting to
the sort of distilling the essence of so
many issues and I would love to see
Katie Porter as the next senator for
representing California
yeah I agree she's my my dad lives in
her district and which it's Newport
Beach which is very you know it's it's
Country Club Republicans but she has a
way of getting through to them and I
think yeah I agree I think Dianne
Feinstein she had her time but she's
coming all the way back to Harvey Milk
like she was the Centrist Democrat going
against Harvey Milk and George Moscow
and I mean I think her time has come
through she said her Legacy but yeah I
don't it's kind of sad from what I've
heard about how she's just kind of not
the same person who she was even a few
years ago so yeah she's been in the
Senate 30 years she was I guess about 59
when she went in she's 89 now it's quite
a run it's nothing to be ashamed of
certainly oh yeah not at all and she was
mayor of San Francisco for 10 years but
anyway yeah I just wanted to kind of get
your perspective I'm hoping Katie Porter
gets the nomination I think she's the
perfect person to win in that state so
all right we will track it closely
all right thanks David Johnny from
Boston great to hear from you as always
let's go next to Dave from Mesquite
Texas Dave from Mesquite Texas
Dave from Mesquite Texas welcome to the
program
if you unmute yourself I will be able to
hear you Dave please
and last chance for Dave from Mesquite
Texas
hi Mr Pacman good to talk with you can
you hear me I can hear you now Dave
welcome sorry about that no problem uh I
live in a suburb of Dallas uh obviously
it's um kind of a small town there's a
bunch of churches here and I kind of had
a question about uh churches in tax
status sure tax uh tax exempt status so
these churches a lot of them are pretty
lavish and they're on really nice uh
pieces of property here
um I would think at some point the the
city would be disincentivized to have
these churches here because uh you know
they're not well the local government's
not getting the uh the property tax the
state certainly isn't
from these uh churches being here yeah I
just don't really know what can be done
because if places start rejecting
churches on the basis that they'd rather
have someone there who will pay taxes I
think it becomes a constitutional issue
pretty quickly certainly the churches
will make it one I think it's
complicated the math of it completely
checks out uh but I just don't know that
that's something that they could easily
get away with
yeah not to mention by the way I mean I
think you also have to consider I don't
know much about Mesquite Texas but my
guess is there's a lot of religious
people there too right it's not just
that there's churches there's Christians
yeah it's definitely the Bible Belt
there's uh it's yeah it's overwhelmingly
Christian churches so my point is
you might not get revenue from the
churches but there's probably people
that live there to be near the churches
and they do pay taxes you know
yeah that's that's true uh well great
thanks for answering that another quick
real question uh that kind of is that
not to do with politics or churches or
tax but uh you and producer Pat have
such great chemistry you guys have to be
buds outside of this out of the show is
that is that an accurate assessment
absolutely we actually ride a tandem
bike regularly and whenever Pat comes to
visit in New York we can be seen on the
streets we wear the same outfit and we
have a tandem bike I do ride in the
front I will admit but uh absolutely
tandem bike nut to butt love it all
right thanks Dave very much appreciate
it hey by the way all right Mesquite I I
don't really understand these Dallas
suburbs does mesquite have its own
downtown of sorts
uh there's an old historic part of
Mesquite it's an old railroad town so uh
the mesquite trees were used to uh fuel
the locomotives back in the day so it's
like an old depot town that kind of got
into cotton farming and kind of grew up
from there but where it I'm looking at
Mesquite on a map it's not like near the
Chick-fil-A is it like where is the
downtown
uh so the downtown is going to be uh uh
Davis between Davis and uh Main Street
kind of between Galloway and Beltline
yeah wow I don't find any of this this
is crazy uh all right well I'm gonna
look into it more closely I want to
learn all about Miss I'm interested in
these Texas suburbs you know they're
just so different
our geography is amazing here you'd love
the the vibe all right well I will have
to get down there soon
there's Dave from Mesquite Texas with
some very very powerful declarations we
are going to speak to more people but
after a very short break so if you're
holding on to talk to me don't hang up
we're going right back to the Discord
lines in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's
speak to a few more people today via
Discord we take calls at
davidpackman.com
Discord if you would like to chat just
raise your hand it's very simple we're
gonna go to Ricardo from Montreal Canada
of course in the province of Quebec
Ricardo welcome to the program what is
on your mind today as you get all of
your various technical issues that I can
tell you're having sorted out
Ricardo from Montreal welcome
hi can you hear me yes I can
perfect hi David this is my first time
ever
show ever
like uh calling or using Discord so I'm
actually kind of nervous right now and
uh and this is my first time ever doing
a call on Discord so well let's make it
a good one Ricardo please
yes so hi David so I know that um I've
actually been following your show since
2020 I've been listening to every single
uh episode on on your show since 2020.
I'm actually a long time listener and um
I just want to ask you a question
because I know I know you've said time
and time and time and time again that
humans are really bad at um predicting
like future events yeah but How likely
uh like do you think it's gonna happen
that America is going to become a
right-wing dictatorship I have I have no
idea you know the thing about these
questions Ricardo is remember during the
State of the Union addresses when Trump
was president and he would say
America will never be a socialist
country do you remember that
I think so I think
that was probably like in 2020 or 2021 I
think
I think or in any case and I would say
Trump is right that America is not about
to be a socialist country there's no
risk of that there's no socialist in
position of power Etc so one of the
things Trump's doing is he's trying to
overstate the risk of a socialist
country but never never is a very long
time I think that's a very dumb
prediction to make 500 years a hundred a
thou who knows you know so will America
be a right-wing dictatorship I have
absolutely no idea it depends on the
decisions that are made and me giving
you an answer definitive answer would be
nothing better than just a wild guess
could America become a right-wing
dictatorship absolutely is it closer now
than it was I don't know 15 years ago I
think the answer is yes but I I beyond
that I don't know
mm-hmm yeah that makes sense so that's a
total um uh valid answer uh but I'm just
I'm just like asking this question
because it's really just from a
perspective of a concerned Canadian
because we're watching we're watching
here from up up here and uh we we
realize what's what's happening
um every single day and uh really just
concerns the heck out of this yeah I I
would be concerned too and listen you
can be a little less concerned than if
you're in the United States so at least
you have that
yeah that that's true that's true but uh
I just really wish uh all the best for
you guys and I just hope that uh you
guys are able to like sort out
everything that's going on there
um like I just really wish the best
because that that just really really
seems uh very concerning and hopeful I
appreciate it normal uh I don't know how
long it will take maybe like 10 years 20
years but we'll see because I know that
um 75 million people voted for Trump in
2020 right uh and um and there's still
like millions and millions of people
that still follow Donald Trump and her
are his still his art and supporters
that will defend him no matter what very
much so so but and and look at the I
think I guess with the 2022 midterms
that was kind of um a good sign because
it just showed a bit like the the waning
power of the Trump Maga movement
um but we'll see we'll see what happens
in like 2024 especially with all the
troubles that Trump is facing right now
I hope so I hope so Ricardo listen uh
Saint Viator or Fairmont Bagel which do
you prefer in Montreal
you think it's better
yeah I think so okay and have you ever
been to Tommy for brunch
oh boy uh my show has millions and
millions of restaurants so
um I don't I don't think I have I don't
know about millions of restaurants but I
recommend it check it out it's a good
spot all right get the eggs benedict
thank you I'm exaggerating I but I know
there's there's quite a few but I heard
that this interesting statistic that
apparently if you were to visit every
single restaurant uh I think three times
a day for the next 18 years you you it
would it would take that amount of time
to visit every single restaurant in
Montreal I believe I believe it Ricardo
I will be back in Montreal soon and I
look forward to it
yeah all right well we'll be happy happy
to have you back all right Ricardo from
Montreal great to hear from you very
very much appreciate it why don't we
speak next you know it's always fraught
to know where we go next when it comes
to phone calls but I believe we're going
to go to Ali from Scotland uh Ali
welcome to the program
oh yeah thanks for having me David
pleasure
it's great to be on
um I actually had a couple of questions
but I'll keep it to one just in the
interest of time
um so the growing debates around you
know transgender youth transgender and
you know adolescence is all over social
media right now and even in mainstream
American discourse and I wonder what
where do you think it's going
um you know at the very top level
obviously every Trump rally he says the
infamous line and then no one should be
allowed to teach transgender yeah to our
children much and it's like what does
that even mean
I know exactly like from a grammatical
point of view and then yeah it just
doesn't make any sense like most of the
stuff he says but where do you think is
going you know here's my hope okay I'm
gonna give you here's my hope of where
the anti-trans stuff among the right is
going my hope is that this is a
temporary stop on the
discrimination and marginalization train
there was a time when the right was
obsessed with gay men they they never
really were that worked up about
lesbians you might remember but like
when I started doing the show they were
obsessed with gay men and now they've
mostly moved on from gay men now trans
is the issue and specifically it's what
they call quote men in women's sports is
a heavy part of it also the things they
claim are being done with regularity
when it comes to Children which are not
actually being done right now that's
their focus and it's really tough for
the people that are being targeted and
marginalized by that my hope is that
eventually they will Tire of the subject
then move on to something else the
problem is who's the next Target right I
feel bad for whoever the next Target is
going to be but there it's just it's
been a shift they've gone from obsession
with going after gay men
now it's the trans stuff there will be a
next thing I don't know what it will be
and when but I I hope they move on soon
although I also want to protect whoever
the next targets are going to be
yeah I think that's absolutely right I
mean I wonder if there's a religious
um you know component to this and and
terms of you know protect the children
save the children the left as they say
the left are attacking our children they
want to sexualize Children which as we
know you know it's not happening you
know they can pick a couple of people on
Tick Tock or write a couple of you know
extreme people in a couple of schools
and the whole of America and they say
this is what the left is doing that's
what they're doing but you know it's
part of it I want to add one item to
this Ollie part of it is yeah
that a lot of the anti-trans stuff when
it comes to kids ties in to their
conspiracy theories about pedophile
Democrats and child sex trafficking and
that type of thing so it's sort of each
has signal boosted the other in a really
convenient way for for these right
Wingers
absolutely no that's absolutely right I
just I wonder where that aspect's going
you know it helps me not the biggest
issue yep and it's not the biggest issue
for me personally either right but you
know it's just something I'm interested
in hey Ollie I have a question for you
the other day someone told me that when
they were in Scotland they ate something
called neeps and tatties do you have any
idea what that is
yeah so that is a Scottish dish which I
don't even like I mean if any Scottish
person's last thing they don't want to
kill me for that but it's basically
potatoes and haggis mixed into one
hey which signs you know taste just as
appealing as a science it's really not
great when you say is it like you mash
up the potatoes and mix in the Haggis I
don't even get what you do I mean to be
honest I've not had it in such a long
time no it's mainly you know more of an
old-fashioned thing got it but um yeah I
mean some people would literally get
their fork and mash it into this one
substance and say that they enjoy it so
wow yeah I wouldn't recommend it David
all right well listen if I go to
Scotland I will look for other forms of
Cuisine definitely all right thank you
for the call I appreciate it
thank you very much Nixon there goes
Ollie from Scotland a very very powerful
message let's go next to Kevin from
Arlington Virginia and see what's
happening in Arlington Kevin welcome to
the program
Hey Kevin I've got a question about last
week's speaker vote please
so you know with hindsight now we know
how to move 15 ballots Kevin McCarthy is
the Speaker of the House
hypothetically speaking
Democrats could have cut that off much
earlier they don't even have to vote for
Kevin McCarthy they could just vote
present not show up so my question is do
you think Democrats ultimately benefited
from holding the line for Hakeem
Jeffries and drawing out the process or
was it really just a big waste of time
no so here's the thing
um yes Democrats could have handed
McCarthy the win earlier by voting
present they lower the necessary
threshold in order to get the
speakership but it's I think that it's
just completely the wrong framing this
is a republican problem it is a
republican problem that they weren't
able to figure out until 15 votes went
by how to get a speaker elected
Democrats have no responsibility to bail
out Republicans Republicans are not
United and Democrats are Republicans are
not interested in actually governing
whereas Democrats are Republicans have
shown in the short time since Kevin
McCarthy became speaker they're not
interested in even dealing with issue
issues that that help the American
people I know that mathematically
Democrats could have acted to make
McCarthy the speaker more quickly but I
believe it was it wasted it's not the
the waste of time isn't even the right
framing
Democrats aren't in control
Democrats wanted Hakeem Jeffries to be
the speaker and there's no reason for
Democrats to become uh uh divorced from
what they actually are which is United
behind Jeffries
to artificially help Kevin McCarthy I I
think it would have been the wrong move
for Democrats to do that on principle
okay makes sense
thanks all right Kevin thank you there's
Kevin from Arlington Virginia uh yeah no
it's a debit but not please we're not
going to blame the Democrats on that one
let's go next to Michael from Scranton
Michael from Scranton welcome to the
program
I um I was wondering
uh I just forgot my question sorry for
swearing and bye all right goodbye
there's Michael from Scranton with a
very very strong appearance on the David
packman show which we love to see let's
go to Magnus from sweet from Sweden
Magnus from Sweden I don't know that you
could have a more perfect called than
the last one but let's try Magnus hello
David Sarah greetings from Sweden can
you hear me I can hear you fine
great Excellency I'll try my best uh
just one question if my lordship again
would be Donald Trump's VP candidate for
the 2024 election do you think this
could benefit the Democrats even further
to it out and vote even more sorry if
what was the first thing if what if if
minority Taylor green would be Donald
Trump's VP candidate oh Marjorie would
it benefit Democrats I you know my
opinion might be different in 2024 right
now
I believe Marjorie Taylor green is
Trump's running mate would further make
obvious that the entire Maga movement is
overtly a joke like it's always been a
joke but it's now overtly a joke Trump
doesn't leave his house he gives weird
interviews and Records these strange
videos and whatever now what could
change my opinion is that Marjorie
Taylor green is now distancing herself
from the crazy magas and trying to align
with the slightly less crazy magas she's
denouncing Lauren bobert and she wants
to be alongside Kevin McCarthy so if
Marjorie Taylor green successfully
aligns herself with the slightly less
crazy part of the Republican Party
maybe her being Trump's VP would be
helpful to him but if it were today I
think green hurts Trump uh as a running
mate
yeah I just think it would be a rather
terrifying thought if minority the green
would be vice president in even worse
president of the United States insane
what happened to Trump if Trump is
president at age 78 and Marjorie Taylor
green is the VP that's a very scary
situation I agree with you
oh I also I saw a curiosity I know we've
been done working many times but have
you ever been to Sweden I've been to
Denmark only once I have never been to
Sweden I was destined to go to Sweden at
the start of the pandemic and then we
all know what happened and now uh it is
very very high on my list I would love
to get to Sweden I think I'd prefer to
go in late spring or something like that
maybe early summer but I I would
absolutely love to go
hey welcome to visit us anytime do you
guys have that uh you you what what's
what are the dishes that Sweden is most
known for
ah it will probably be the traditional
Swedish meatballs and mashed potatoes
and the linger Jam of course right and
is it better in Sweden than at IKEA
well I think it would be a rather
authentic okay yeah sorry perfectly fine
yeah I've tasted him in another country
some yeah
just about like the Swedish one so okay
very good I look forward to trying that
no I I will absolutely announce when I
will be entering Sweden awesome all
right Magnus thank you for the call
cheers all right there is a very very
strong strong phone call let's go to
Scipio from California a very devoted
website member at davidpackman.com
Scipio welcome to the show what's on
your mind
sir David sir protector of the realm sir
do I sound okay you sound great
okay awesome uh so I have a politics and
a food question for you okay
um so we all know the McCarthy debacle
that kind of just ended
um with the speaker how do you think
that's going to affect the Republican
Party specifically
going into 2024 uh into the general
election it's too early to say the
question is can Republicans credibly
make the case that they are now United
and stand for something over the two
years that they are going to govern or
does this rupture or fracture get worse
and worse and devolve into more partisan
infighting it's we just we have to wait
and see I don't think we know yet
okay
um very good then the food question I
have for you is I'm Mexican-American so
there's a lot of
Mexican Cuisine that I like but I know
you're from Argentina right is there any
Argentinian I don't know if that's the
right way to put it uh is there any
dishes from Argentina that uh I should
try or that you recommend absolutely I
mean there's there's just so many I mean
Argentinian style empanadas would be
very very high on the list we're talking
about oven baked not deep fried do you
understand what I'm saying right yeah
yeah we're not gonna throw those things
in a deep fryer and just fry them into
submission we're going to bake them
um the thing about a lot of Argentinian
food is that it really it's from
somewhere else like one of my favorite
dishes is milanesa but the the term
Milan Italy is literally in the name
it's really an Italian Dish you know the
the thing about Argentinian dishes
there's Argentinian style pizza which is
its own thing but Pizza is not strictly
speaking Argentinian you know
um there are so many things to try but
the oranges of many of them are really
in other countries
oh okay well uh like I said oranges uh
great well thanks for taking my call I
really appreciate it I hope you have a
good rest of your day all right Scipio
from California always great to speak to
you folks that's all I've got I know
there's 50 people who are Furious I know
it I know it but I can't get to
everybody every time we will take calls
again and I hope to speak to you soon
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
let's get into the listener and viewer
mailbag if you have something to say
it's info davidpackman.com sometimes we
will highlight a YouTube comment or a
tweet or what else yeah it could be
anything but it's mostly emails sent to
info davidpackman.com we're going to
start today with Norma Jean Norma Jean
is upset
I find these emails a little funny
Norma Jean wrote in and said about
Michael Cohen with a sad face hi David I
discovered your show on Tick Tock and
have been listening to your podcast ever
since thank you for being a voice of
reason in a crazy time look forward and
look forward to subscribing one question
I was surprised that you would have
agreed to be on Michael Cohen's podcast
can you clarify and talk a little about
why you chose to be on his podcast given
his sketchy past to include tax and bank
fraud in addition to being disbarred by
the New York Supreme Court yikes how
does he have any credibility left thank
you yeah you know I mean listen
um I
appearing on a show
is not an endorsement of everything that
person has done and if you go down this
path sort of like where do you draw the
line I mean I'm sure everybody who's
interviewed me has lied some of them
have also cheated on their significant
others that arguably could be a reason
for me to refuse to appear on some other
shows I mean this isn't how I think
about things you know
um you get invited to lots of shows and
the question is is it worthwhile
speaking to the audience of that show
and the answer with Michael Cohen's show
was yes so I appeared on the show it's
it's really just that it doesn't mean
that I think it was okay when Michael
Cohen committed bank fraud or when some
other interviewer you know cheated on
their spouse as many of the people that
have interviewed me it's I'm not
endorsing anything in particular
I'm just doing the show so I I would
just say don't think too much about that
um yeah maybe I'll just leave it there
Andrew wrote in and said also be fun to
see you respond to this on one of your
videos don't you will as it is one of
your fake emails at the beginning I felt
your channel had potential but you went
extreme left and you now becoming a
failure no wonder you need to endorse
businesses that are scam for money you
are desperate you know what's really
funny
this is a really common so I've talked
about unsubscribed trolls right which
are
now I'm unsubscribing and it's like you
were never subscribed
uh this one is I used to have positive
feelings about your show but because of
the things you did I no longer do I went
back and checked out the email history
the reason so we keep all emails that
are sent in sometimes because law
enforcement needs them I know that
that's really sad but unfortunately in
this era
the
when you've been doing this as long as
we've been doing it
and your audience is a certain size it
starts to become likely that some of
your viewers are going to be entangled
with law enforcement and uh we keep all
records in case
um we may at some point need to turn
them over to law enforcement but also
just to see for example Andrew has been
writing in literally for years and every
email has been riddled with insults and
pejoratives and uh all sorts of stuff he
never thought that channel had potential
he's been insulting me since day one and
uh the other funny thing is now you're
becoming a failure the show is bigger
today than it has ever been before
might have been better earlier to say
your show will never be bigger or
something like that but okay that's
Andrew very very important message
um trolllay wrote in and said Trump
claims he can't be anti-semitic because
he moved the embassy to Jerusalem
so many Christians also seem to claim to
love Israel but they hate Jews
many fundamentalist Christians believe
it is their duty to bring about
Armageddon as a step to bring about the
Rapture do you think the president
actually did it to placate these people
as Jerusalem becoming the capital is a
step in that goal excellent question
I've explained so many times American
Jews are very liberal one of the most
left-wing voting blocs in the United
States and yet you often hear
but what about Republicans as the
supporters of Israel
Republicans support Israel in a very
narrow way that is connected to the
Evangelical beliefs about as this email
is pointing out the Rapture Armageddon
the second coming of Jesus etc etc they
don't like or or like isn't even the
right word
they aren't
about the Jewish people as a people as a
culture as a community
they believe their teachings in which
Jews and Israel have a particular role
to play in Jesus Jesus coming back and
Rapture and Armageddon and all of this
other crazy stuff and yes the Jerusalem
thing is part of that I don't know that
Trump had any idea about that Trump's
view most likely was
the people on my side who talk to me
about Israel
want the embassy in Jerusalem so that's
good and that's probably as far as Trump
really is aware but a very good question
and very accurately uh pointed out there
Michael wrote in about
oversimplification of political issues
and this is also a good topic says David
started watching a few months ago really
liked the show have you ever noticed how
many right-wing positions are based on
Gross oversimplification of the issues
climate change it still snows therefore
global warming is a hoax gender just
look between your legs poverty just work
harder immigration just come in Legally
mental illness just snap out of it
systemic oppression pull yourself up by
your bootstraps abortion it's always
murder STDs just don't have sex covet
vaccine you still get covid so it's
useless homelessness go to a shelter
drug addiction just stop using and it
makes sense you have to be that out of
touch with how things work for everyday
people to be a right winger yeah this is
this is a big academic topic and Michael
Michael may have stumbled upon this on
his own but people like George lakeoff
and others have talked about how the
framing that the right uses for so many
issues is linguistically advantageous
and it contributes to the Simplicity we
need tax relief
taxes are a burden lower taxes people
are relieved that's good
right but you can't lower them to zero
then Society ceases to function abortion
well I'm pro-life everybody else must be
against life life is good so being this
is actually a really big Topic in the
American political divide and Michael is
completely right that the only way that
you would believe this stuff is if you
really are out of touch or lack
information or you know we've talked
about the different categories but this
is a this is a feature of Republican
politics not a bug because it makes it
so that completely untenable political
positions
seem almost viable to some people by
virtue of their fabricated simplicity
um Michael wrote in about conservative
Checkmate and says you should benefit
from how you are registered to vote if
you register as a conservative I guess
Michael means a republican you get to
keep your total wage and pay no taxes
but in return you get no Services no
police no fire no Health Care you would
have to pay out of pocket for those
Services if you register as a Democrat
you pay 30 to 40 percent in taxes but
you get health care Social Security fire
police Etc would conservatives be okay
with this idea now I know that this I
think anyway that this is a thought
experiment from Michael and it's one
we've explored before
um in practice I don't know what the
average right wing Winger would say
listen you get to keep all your money
but you've got to pay for every road
that you use I mean it sort of starts to
become kind of like one of these
libertarian Utopias which don't work at
all
um I don't know what they would say but
obviously we all know that this type of
thinking is completely impossible for
any functioning Society but it'd be a
curious one to uh to ask them about for
sure
Anthony wrote In from Spain and says I'm
a long time fan from Spain sorry for my
English it's my fourth language it's a
little subtle brag there I wanted to ask
you if you've ever considered doing some
Spanish language videos I want to
recommend you to some of my
acquaintances who do not believe me when
I tell them about how bad U.S politics
are I also hear there's loads of
disinformation in Spanish both here and
in the U.S and I don't know of any
Spanish-speaking equivalent to your show
I know it would probably have lower Roi
but you are one of the few that could
reach that public without sounding
condescending since you're a native
Spanish speaker so we've been looking to
do this for a while I just don't have
any time in my day to produce content in
Spanish in addition to what I'm doing
but we are about to Launch
a dubbed version of our Clips to Spanish
so you'll see me
The Voice will be dubbed into Spanish
and I know I know I know I know I know I
know it's not perfect it's not perfect I
just don't have any any more time guys
uh it you know we've got the live
streams and we've got the podcast and
the YouTube channel and the finance
Channel and you know my my daughter is
needing diaper changes I thought I only
needed like three diapers for the entire
first year it turns out you need way
more than three diapers for that it's
crazy I just can't I can't do more
content in Spanish
so we're going to be doing a dubbing
thing I think it could do quite well and
I'll tell you more about it when it uh
when it launches Landon wrote in about
Trump and says past presidents have
airports named after them perhaps a
prison can be named after Trump of
course preferably with him locked inside
nice one Landon I'm I'm that's a
presented without comment I won't even
comment on that and then Dwayne wrote in
about voter fraud and says David I'm
curious as to how many cases of voter
fraud that have been prosecuted from
2020 to the end of 22 have been
Republicans compared to Democrats I keep
seeing a case it seems like every other
week and it is not a Democrat it's as if
any claim a republican makes of a crime
is basically an admission of a crime
they have done I may not be a smart man
but I know I'm seeing a pattern here
thank you Dwight yeah so you know part
of this is does some voter fraud go
under the radar but of the prosecuted
cases in the U.S and there are very few
it is overwhelmingly Republicans and
it's often Republicans trying to prove a
point and then the prove they point the
point they prove is the opposite they
want to prove how easy it is to get away
with it then they get caught
um Sometimes some Republicans were
caught genuinely voting twice like for
their some in some cases a dead relative
we've seen these things anecdotally big
picture there's very little voter fraud
happening at the micro level for those
who get prosecuted it is mostly
Republicans Dwayne is absolutely correct
send in your thoughts comments questions
to info
davidpackman.com sign up at
joinpakman.com to get all of our great
member benefits including instant access
to the bonus show which you could go
watch or listen to right now if you were
already a member